Bundespolizei bitte
ID Card
Schwerpunktkontrolle illegale Migration
an der Grenze zur Schweiz where you
coming from now
die Zahl der illegalen einreisen hat
sich hier zuletzt mehr als vervierfacht
die Bundespolizei hat ihre Kontrollen
daher intensiviert
jeden Tag greifen Sie hier Flüchtlinge
auf
und Screen so auch heute
Basel in der Schweiz für Fabian Olpe und
seine Kolleginnen von der Bundespolizei
geht es gleich in den ICE nach
Deutschland zur Kontrolle Schwerpunkt
heute
illegale Migration eine Vereinbarung mit
der Schweiz ermöglicht es der deutschen
Bundespolizei schon auf Schweizer
Staatsgebiet zu kontrollieren noch bevor
der Zug die Grenze passiert
unsere Kontrollen beginnen sobald der
Zug anfährt und auf der kurzen Strecke
zwischen Basel SBB und Baden Bahnhof
kontrollieren wir dann und würden dann
etwaige Person aus dem Zug nehmen sie
starten vom hintersten Wagen aus
kontrollieren stichprobenartig die
Ausweise der Reisenden
danke schön schönen Tag
guten Tag Bundespolizei ausweis bitte
auch hier ist alles in Ordnung einige
Wagen später ist das anders
hallo haben Sie einmal ausweis bitte
Card where you coming from now
eine fünfköpfige Familie zwei Erwachsene
drei Kinder sie hätten keine Ausweise
dabei sagen sie das ist Action
die Familie muss ihr Gepäck nehmen den
Zug am Badischen Bahnhof Basel verlassen
ein deutscher Bahnhof war aber immer
noch auf Schweizer Staatsgebiet hier
werden Ihre Daten nun gleich aufgenommen
einige Stunden zuvor in Weil am Rhein
auf deutscher Seite direkt hinter der
Grenze auch hier kontrolliert die
Bundespolizei stichprobenartig unter
anderem in der Straßenbahn die von Basel
aus über die Grenze fährt
die Personen werden aufgeforderten
Ausweis zu bezahlen und dann aus das
Dokument zu zeigen wenn die das können
ist alles in Ordnung und wenn eben die
Person das nicht vorzeigen kann wird
sich aus der Bahn genommen und dann
einer Polizei rechtlichen Kontrolle
durch uns hier vor Ort unterzogen 12
Stunden dauert die Schicht von Fabian
Olten und seinem Team immer wieder
wechseln Sie währenddessen den
kontrollort Morgen Bundespolizei eine
Einreisekontrolle bitte auch wenn der
Schwerpunkt der Kontrolle heute auf
illegaler Migration liegt überprüfen Sie
routinemäßig auch andere Dinge
Drogenschmuggel etwa oder ob ein
Haftbefehl gegen eine Person vorliegt
das können Sie direkt an ihren Dienst
Smartphones abklären
danke schön hier gibt es an diesem
Morgen keinen Treffer
danke schönen Tag
am Badischen Bahnhof Basel ist die
afghanische Familie aus dem ICE
inzwischen an der sogenannten
bearbeitungsstraße angekommen zunächst
werden hier Fingerabdrücke genommen
die weiteren Schritte sind dann die
Registrierung also die
erkennungsdienstliche Behandlung mit
Speicherung der Fingerabdrücken und
Fotografien die Befragung der Menschen
zu ihrem einreiseweg zum einreisegrund
anders als noch im Zug angegeben hat die
Familie doch Pässe dabei was die
Feststellung der Identität erleichtert
mit der Polizei aber auch mit uns
spricht der Vater anschließend über die
Flucht aus Afghanistan
sechs Monate sind wir jetzt unterwegs
durch elf Länder durch sind viel zu Fuß
gegangen mit meinen Söhnen auch per Auto
und Zug gefahren jetzt sind wir hier
[Musik]
sein Vater sah bei der Polizei deshalb
seien sie von den Taliban bedroht worden
er wolle seine Familie in Sicherheit
bringen erzählt der Mann
ich möchte nach Deutschland Teile meiner
Familie sind da mein Cousin ich will in
Deutschland leben
[Musik]
doch weil die Bundespolizei ihn noch auf
Schweizer Boden aufgegriffen hat endet
die Reise der Familie hier in Basel die
Menschen werden wenn sie hier erfasst
und registriert sind den
schweizerbehörden Angeboten die
entscheiden dann zum weiteren Vorgehen
geflüchtete können dann in der Schweiz
einen Asylantrag stellen doch viele
wollen das nicht versuchen so lange die
Grenze nach Deutschland zu überwinden
bis sie deutsches Staatsgebiet erreicht
haben da entscheidet dann letztlich das
Bundesamt für Migration über das Asyl
gesucht
Fabian Olten und sein Team verlagern
ihre Kontrolle jetzt an den
autobahngrenzübergang Weil am Rhein
guten Tag sprechen sie deutsch
mittlerweile links reinfahren sehr gerne
wir haben hier einfach die Autobahn mit
als größten grenzübertrittsstelle von
der Schweiz nach Deutschland
da gibt es natürlich etliche Wege auch
von der Schweiz nach Deutschland zu
kommen Privat PKW Taxis da liegen wir
den Wert drauf dass wir die
stichprobenartige kontrollieren und dann
eben festgestellt habe hier illegale
Migration vorliegt oder nicht die Zahl
der illegalen einreisen über die Schweiz
nach Deutschland ist in den letzten
Monaten deutlich angestiegen hat sich
etwa zwischen 2021 und 2022 mehr als
vervierfacht vor allem aus Afghanistan
Syrien und der Türkei über die
sogenannte Balkanroute Polizeiarbeit ist
nie ganz ungefähr
täglichen Arbeit hier im Rahmen der
Migration vereinzelt Widerstände und
ähnliche Gewaltanwendungen gegen uns
aber eben der Großteil der Menschen ist
kooperativ folgt unseren Maßnahmen
Fabian Olten ist seit 2021 bei der
Bundespolizei hier in der Grenzregion
zur Schweiz war davor bei der
Landespolizei diese beiden Kolleginnen
sind ganz neu hier waren davor
zweieinhalb Jahre in Ausbildung
bei mir ist es jetzt so ich kann jetzt
sage ich mal was ich in der Schule
gelernt habe hier festigen auch und
jetzt die ersten Aufgriffe konnten wir
gut abarbeiten weiß der ist ja wie soll
ich sagen großes dabei es ist uns
Schwierigkeiten bereitet haben wir haben
immer und Ansprechperson bei uns jetzt
auch bei den ersten paar Monaten die uns
dann zur Rat und Tat zur Seite steht
Polizei war grundsätzlich immer schon in
Kindheitstraum und dann habe ich
angefangen mich so ein bisschen zu
informieren und Landespolizei war mir zu
eingeschränkt also ich wollte mich nicht
auf einen Bundesland beschränken und
wollte gerne mehr von Deutschland sehen
und ähm ja mehr von Deutschland sehen
und Polizeiarbeit bin ich hier ja genau
richtig als nächstes erwarten Sie einen
Fernbus dessen Passagiere sie dann kurz
hinter der Grenze kontrollieren
irgendein Pass Dokumente dabei
in diesem Bus dürfen alle weiterfahren
wer keine gültigen Papiere hat wird an
eine bearbeitungsstraße auf deutscher
Seite registriert so wie diese beiden
jungen Männer die gerade von einer
Streife im deutschen Lörrach
aufgegriffen wurden sie kommen aus
Afghanistan
während meiner Schulzeit habe ich
Privatkurse in Englisch gegeben in der
Stadt haben ein paar Leute falsche
Informationen an die Taliban gegeben sie
sagten dieser Mann arbeitet mit den
amerikanischen Soldaten zusammen ich
hatte Angst dass sie mir etwas antun
sich auf den langen Weg nach Deutschland
machte hier jetzt Asyl beantragen will
das darf er anders als die Familie die
am Vormittag in Basel aufgegriffen wurde
der Unterschied ist dass die Menschen
hier auf Deutsch moritzgebiet
aufgegriffen worden sind und dann neben
der Registratur und
erkennungsdienstlichen Behandlung die
wir auch in Basel gesehen haben hier
zusätzlich angezeigt werden wegen
unerlaubte Einreise und nach der
strafrechtlichen Bearbeitung wenn sie
asylsucht Vorbringen dann werden Sie
weitergeleitet an die Landes
Erstaufnahmestelle während die Erfassung
der beiden Männer in der
bearbeitungsstraße noch läuft geht die
Arbeit an der Grenze weiter eine Arbeit
bei der die Beamten immer wieder auch
mit heftigen Schicksalen konfrontiert
werden
das ist Konflikt würde nicht sagen aber
natürlich ein Spannungsfeld in dem wir
uns als Polizeibeamtinnen und
Polizeibeamte bewegen das trennen können
zu müssen eben Dienst zwischen unserem
gesetzlichen Auftrag den wir dort zu
erfüllen haben und das was wir
menschlich vielleicht nachvollziehen
können die Gründe der Flucht der
Menschen und ähnliches wie die Lage hier
an der Schweizer Grenze sich
weiterentwickeln wird das wissen sie
nicht man werde die Situation weiter
beobachten sagt das
Bundesinnenministerium und die
kontrollintensität entsprechend anpassen
[Musik]